YouTube tips
The first 15 seconds
Make compelling content first
*Silent fart*
Aw, shiet.
Start off with something that will  immediately grab attention.
TOP OF THE MORNIN' TO YA LADDIES!
WHAT IS UUUUPPPP!!
Michal, Vsauce here.
*Eardrum bleeding*
Make it clear what your videos about
I don't even know what this video is going to be about.
I never know what the video is (stutter/laugh) going to be about
Uhh....
*snapping*
this video is about watchtime
tease the rest of the video so the audience is intrigued to see where you take them
SEXY PAPA PEWDS: I'ma take you out for the best time of your god damned life
you've clicked videos before, but you have not clicked this video
look in my eyes
and tell me that you will never click away
I'm gonna make you feel nice
I'ma feel, make you feel safe
I'm going to touch you like no other person has touch- (Ou shit :0)
can I say that?
Share your channel branding later
A flashy intro may look cool, but it´s not the star of the video
Goddamit!, I need a flash intro
Que the flash Intro, you son of a bitch!
*DEAFINATOR X3000*
Fuck yeah! That was a goood intro
Well, this YouTube blog is really informative
It teaches youtubers how to get better,
How come there's nothing about watchtime?
Can't even espel it
What do u mean watch time, Pewdiepie?
*farting noises*
So for those who don't know. Watchtime is YouTube's ne-new lil baby
is like
FUCK VIEWS
Noo YES! OH IT'S MEEEEE AGAIN!
Hai guys I want to be included
Talking about Youtube, technicalities.
To that one special person who saw this.... Thank you senpai. :,)
He's going to leave.
Fakeout.
fuck you. I need this video to be ten minutes
I'm a go play pokemon go. Go go. and Go as in take a shit, so he's going to triple go! Mind blown.
but you are moving...
Why ten?
No you won't...
Just skip to the end nothing happens.
HAIII GUYS
*Door shutting
*Cough Cough*
Hi.
Hi! -subtitler illuminati
How are you?
good thank you.
Not much of a talker huh?
What do you mean I said hi!
Subscribe to youtube.com/arina86
Nice to meet you eh? My name is caption.
Uh...
Pewds is hilarious. We know that.
...
And in it for the money.
But I thought I might share something with you.
y'all should follow my insta
@natalieolivia12
...
I wonder what kind of statement pewds made with that... Much social commentary, wow.
Anyways, I'm glad to have spent this time with you.
I don't understand any of this watchtime stuff...
Nor why there are so many Non-English subtitles in an English caption track...
#MakeAmericaGreatAgain
Hahaha, JK, I don't give a shit about politics.
Well, kind of. I wouldn't want Clinton to win to be honest. (no offense to all Clinton supporters)
Who cares, We are so much more than an elitist's struggle for control with other elitists.
So much political non-sense these days while bad people get away with stomping on the good...
One day we will rise...
my goats like it when i tickle their belly button.
i also put my wee wee i their belly button sometimes. I LOVE MY LIFE
Sorry, I got distracted...
...
Be safe out there alright?
Friend?
Will you be my friend?
I think we can be friends...
I got your back and you got mine even if we've never met.
It's funny because we may never meet...
Or we might... But we'll never know who any of us actually are...
We all develop these internet personalities and identities...
But most of the time those are like our secret little lives...
HAHA, it is i! the evil subtitle changer!. Ok look im sorry but this subtitle was just a link ok? Dont get mad over it, and hey change it all you want after this. Also hey wanna hear a joke? ok so why can't dinosaurs talk? because their all dead! haha, hilarious right? No? well im just gonna sit here in silence then *sits in silence*
Watch out... And Goodbye my friend...
Pito will ruin the world, pay attention 7u7